good evening members and
we have no members of the public
welcome um
some housekeeping to start
fire alarm procedures if the fire alarm
is activated vacate the offices via the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assembling hawley square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phones and do not make or receive
calls while the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
i don't believe we have anyone here to
film the meeting this evening so i can
pass straight to
item h which is the
following members have asked to speak
under council procedure rule 20.1 item 5
councillor whitehead item 6 councillor
everett item 7 councillor whitehead
does any other member wish to speak
under 20.1
no sorry
so you wish to speak under item nine
okay
okay
i have no apologies for absence because
we are all present this evening
does anyone have any interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
it's a no chance
minutes of the previous meeting i need
to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
extraordinary cabinet meeting held on
the 22nd of february 2022 and a copy is
attached to our agenda pack
i propose we approve the minutes do i
have a seconder councillor bob baker
do members agree
minutes of a previous meeting to approve
the summary of recommendations and
decision of the cabinet meeting held on
the 27th of january 2022 the copy is
also attached to the agenda pack i
propose we approve the minutes do i have
a secondary council bob baker
do members agree
item 5
adoption of revised tenancy strategy and
tenancy management strategy
to introduce councillor jill baffert
thank you leader
the local
localism act 2011 requires the council
to develop and publish a tenancy
strategy setting out the council's
preferred position on the type of
tenancies granted by registered
providers of social housing in the
district
the strategy is advisory
and used by social landlords as guidance
the act also requires the council as a
social housing landlord itself to
produce a management policy which sets
out how authentic district council will
operationally grant and manage tenancies
the tenancy strategy and management
policy last published by the district
council in 2018 needs a news update
the tenancy strategy sets out the
council's position on the use of fixed
term tenancies affordable and sociable
rent mutual exchanges succession rights
and arrangements for dealing with
tenancy fraud
in most respects the strategy
recommended remains the same as that
taken in 2018.
one significant difference relates to
the use of fixed term tenancies
in light of national and local changes
and attitude to their use this report
recommends that they should not be used
as a preferred tenancy type
one of the original objectives of fixed
term tenancies was to enable social
housing providers to make the best use
of social housing stock
and not renew tenancies when households
no longer had a need for that home
in reality however this has not led to
an increased turnover of tenants and
social and social landlords have not
used the legislation to end tenancies in
this way
experiences from across social housing
providers including tdc
have identified a number of problems
with the use of fixed term tendencies
these include tenants feeling concerned
and anxious about their futures based on
their tenure type
lack of investment by families in their
home and community because they feel
they will have to move on
little impact in terms of stock turnover
and vacancies
potential conflict with the government
priority to give tenants a stronger
voice
significantly administrative costs
involved with this scheme particularly
where the majority of tenancies are set
to continue
we have consulted with the council's
tenants about the proposed new strategy
a small number of tenants contact the
council as a result of the consultation
and expressed support for the proposal
to end the use of fixed term tenancies
i move the recommendations set out in
the report
thank you councillor bayford do i have a
seconder
councillor bob bayford
to speak under
rule 20.1 councillor whitehead
thank you leader and thank you very much
councillor bayford
i'd just like to say how much i welcome
our long-term choice to recognize
tenants rights to security of tenure
being formalized
the housing and planning act in effect
sought to solve the continuing shortage
of social and affordable housing by
making fixed-term tendencies mandatory
rather than simply accepting that we
desperately need to build more social
and genuinely affordable housing
and that tenants deserve the security of
lifetime tenancies
i'm glad that we have chosen never to
formally use this facility to end
tenancies and i am very glad that we are
now formally disposing of it
we cannot dispose of tenant security to
make up for flaws in the overall system
the issue is the central government
choosing not to build social housing
regardless of the clear level of need
and removing lifetime tenancies was
always a damaging policy
as such i find it very positive and
noteworthy that as a council we are
rejecting a central policy that didn't
work and that was instituted for
entirely the wrong reasons
i note that although we have contacted
registered providers we have had no
contact to confirm their recognition of
our preferences
as we trust them to provide a comparable
level of security for our residents can
i ask if we will be following up to
establish their response to our
proposals
thank you
thank you councillor whitehead
councillor bayford
thank you councillor whitehead i welcome
your comments and i'm sure we will be
following this up as you as you
suggested thank you
so cabinet this has been uh moved and
seconded do members agree
thank you
item six
budget monitoring 2021-22
report number three
to introduce councillor david saunders
thank you leader this report covers
quarter free general fund revenue and
capital reflecting the latest forecasts
in the light of the kovic pandemic
together with the housing revenue
account hra and is the third budget
monitor
for the 2021
22 period
the quarter free forecast is for a 1.95
million pound overspend on this year's
budget the details are shown in table 1
and summarized on pages
49-54
the hra forecast is for a 226 000 pound
surplus against budget as shown in table
2. general fund capital programme report
together with the hri report are shown
on nx1 and 2 on pages 60 and 61.
i commend the report and propose the
report
thank you council saunders do i have a
secondary councillor bob bayford's
speaking under 20.1 councillor everett
yeah thank you leader um i just have uh
i'm counseling yates for this evening by
the way because he's unwell um
i just have a one comment and a couple
of questions uh one comment is about um
i know the the cost to the council of uh
implementing um
the council tax energy payment of 150
pounds and the this anticipated this
will be recovered under new burdens
funding i hope it is because i think the
government has a history of
dumping responsibilities on local
government and not not repaying it in
full
um
i also note that the shortfall in the
the crematorium income i think it is i
just i just wonder uh and i don't mean
this facetiously is that because fewer
people have died in in 2122 or is there
something else going on in the in the
demand for
those services in stanley i mean it
could well be because it may well be
that we saw um extra people die in 2021
and that there's been a um you know some
of the people who would have died in 21
22 died in the previous year i just
don't know whether we've got any any any
insight into that and i think the most
the most serious point i wanted to make
is around um covering the deficit um i
know that i think there was a million
pound from the previous year which was
carried forward with the intention of
plugging this deficit because it does
arise uh pretty largely from covid
and it talks about the anticipated
further payment i think
um
is that anticipated do what what sort of
what certainty do we have that we're
actually going to get that money because
obviously it would leave a rather a
large hole in our budget if we didn't
get it
and i wouldn't like us to end up
spending the new homes bonus which as we
know we've earmarked for paying off old
debt with
so what can officers tell us about that
thank you
thank you councillor everett councillor
saunders um you have three questions
there i believe so um
thank you for the uh
highlighting the uh 150 pound uh
payment um
there also is concern on this side with
regards to the administration of that
and how it dovetails in
particularly when you look at the
requirement that that will be paid into
individual bank accounts as i understand
it so there will be a need to
solicit bank account details for those
people who are not paying by direct
debit so
we're looking at that very carefully
as far as the
crematorium figures
i don't personally have those and i
don't know if matt behind me can answer
the question on that
the other point is yes
we are anticipating
the payment that you mention
but
as you quite rightly say
nothing certain until we actually
receive that payment but thus far with
regards to covid um costs have been
covered with the monies that we've
received from central government
i think that's absolutely correct and i
don't know if matt can help us with
figures from the crematorium etcetera
yeah thank you it's exactly what you
said it is um it's just that profile
effectively it's outside the office's
control it just is what it is as a
result of the impacts of
with regards to the grants
we have been submitting our claims
there's nothing to indicate that we
won't receive that money all the other
payments have come as and when so we'll
continue to return the claims as they
are and anticipate that money being
received
thank you uh matt thank you um
councillor saunders does that cover
the points i believe so um okay i can
add um i actually visited the
crematorium with um having weight um on
other
matters but um it was i did have a
a a tour round and it was noted by um
the team up there that there had been a
reduction in the amount of um
cremations that were happening um and it
probably is as as matt said it is a
result of it it's sort of balancing out
from the uh
the massive uh sad loss of what occurred
during the kobe
period the height of the period um gavin
you want to come in on that as well
there's also a new crematorium just been
built in handbare
but the issue there is is they're also
running their own sort of funeral
services as well
and that's upset quite a lot of the
local funeral directors so it's not been
used extensively at the moment but
obviously wants to sort that problem out
then we're likely to see more pressure
on the budget from from people using
that facility as well
and obviously um we are looking at a
program of maybe to um extend our
services as well there is um
you know so
people can have a a smoother sort of
all-round
um
service solution so um it's something
that we need to keep an eye on um
obviously so uh
i think uh it's been
uh moved and seconded do members agree
agreed
so item seven is the adoption of the
following policies asb rechargeable
works income collection aids and
adaptions to introduce councillor jill
bayford
thank you leader
this report proposes four policies
covering aspects of the council's tenant
leaseholder service
the four policies are
income recovery including enforcement
evictions
and evictions
rechargeable works orders
anti-social behaviour
aids and adapt adaptations
the policy has to have been reviewed by
the senate tenant and leaseholder group
housing of cabinet advisory group and
the overview and scrutiny panel
as key policies they are important
documents that set out the standards
that the council will provide these
services to for tenants and leaseholders
it is important that tenants and
leaseholders know what to expect from
the service
the policies also provide officers with
the tools they need to enable them to
carry out their jobs
we set out to make the policies easy to
understand and as success succeeds as
possible and will ensure that they are
published on the council's website and
accessible to our tenants and
leaseholders
i move the recommendation set out in the
report to adopt the draft policies
thank you councillor baker do i have a
secondary councillor bob bayford a bit
of a double act tonight going there from
the bayfoods
[Laughter]
to speak under 20.1 councillor whitehead
thank you leader and thank you
councillor bayford
um i'd just like to say that the tenant
and leaseholder support for these
policies was very strong within the
tenant and leaseholder group
and it's still very pleasing to see how
well that group is working
just in relation to paragraph 3.3
it states that useful feedback was given
to a couple of points within the
policies leading to word changes to
reduce assumptions which serve to
enhance them the recognition that
perpetrators of asb may also need
support was welcomed
and i was the individual who raised
concerns in relation to antisocial
behavior as i am reasonably frequently
contacted by residents with additional
needs or with children with additional
needs
and those needs can sometimes be
expressed in a way that can create
difficulties within shared blocks or
even with close neighbors
in recognition of this and of the fact
that antisocial behavior can often not
be a deliberate act and insert is
sometimes an expression of a need or a
disability
i was wondering if it would be possible
to consider changing the word
perpetrators to those involved in
antisocial behaviour to remove the
potential blame and stigma linked to
that particular word thank you
thank you councillor whitehead would you
like to respond counselor thank you
councillor whitehead um
i can't see any reason why we couldn't
make that change i'd agree it would
would perhaps be more appropriate how do
you feel about that
you're happy with that so we'll do that
thank you very much thank you very much
so that has been agreed on minuted
and we have moved and seconded do
members agree
item 8
tenant and leaseholder services key
performance indicators
quarter three
to introduce again councillor jill
bayford thank you
thank you leader
this report covers both our progress on
tenant and leaseholder health and safety
compliance and provides an update on the
overall performance of the tenant
leaseholder service
firstly i'm really pleased to announce
that the regulatory notice that was
placed on the council in 2019 was
removed on the 24th of february 2022
i'm really happy that uh the hard work
put in by the team has been rewarded
this has been accomplished by the hard
work and dedication of the entire team
who have pulled together to improve our
position on landlord compliance
the report shows that most work streams
are operating as as business as usual
but two areas that are still in recovery
are electrical safety and fire risk
assessment actions
the team has a robust action plan in
place to resolve by the end of march and
are making good progress
more widely the team's performance
remains steady in most areas for quarter
three
the planned works program is progressing
as expected
with only two projects that are
experiencing delays
at royal crescent in ramsgate there has
been a delay with the tender documents
due to the complexity of the works
required and the need to carry out
additional inspections and surveys
we anticipate being ready to procure for
this
project in april
at church fields in margate a fire risk
assessment identified a lack of
compartmentation
in the loft space
this therefore had to be resolved as an
emergency project and the
compartmentation works are being
completed now
the planned project for new bin stores
and parking that was approved by cabinet
in november will be planned into the
22-23 program
the reporter report also identifies
areas of performance that need to
improve
one key area for improvement is the
turnaround time for void properties
disappointingly for the team this has
not improved since transition
to address this they have restructured
sorry
to create a dedicated voids team and
change the way they work with the
contractors to complete void works
further works to improve turnaround
times is taking place during
quarter four as the team
streamline processes systems and
communication
the rent area's position has declined in
quarter three when compared to quarter
two this is an area that had previously
been improving since transition
however the position is better than the
position at quarter three last year
and comparison with previous years and
other providers shows that an increase
in arrears during quarter three which
includes the christmas period is not
unusual
i recommend that cabinet notes the
report
thank you councillor bayford do i have a
secondary
councillor george cup
i don't believe we have uh
i don't believe we have anyone to speak
under 20.1 on this one so um
do members agree
item nine ramsgate conservation area
appraisal oh i think that's me to
introduce
it's me
gotta do some work now
this item proposes
to move to council for the adoption of
the ramsgate conservation area appraisal
and management plan this follows public
consultation of the documents which were
produced as part of the ramsgate
heritage action zone work at the end of
last year
since being designated in 1970 and
subsequently extended five times there
hasn't been an appraisal of the
conservation era in ramsgate
the appraisal and plan have been
produced from the work of the local
community and supporting consultants to
provide a highly detailed evaluation of
the features and characters that make
ramsgate conservation area so important
this excellent piece of work and i do
believe it is an excellent piece of work
has been ongoing
across different administrations of the
council and i'm sure all members will
want to thank the local community
especially the ramsgate society and
ramsgate heritage and design forum whose
voluntary work has made this appraisal
possible
the report before cabinet outlines the
background behind the has and the
appraisal provides a summary of the
structure of the appraisal and the key
recommendations from the management plan
produced for
for all stakeholders
it outlines the results of the
consultation which occurred between the
1st of november and the 13th of december
last year which was support
supportive of the appraisal and
management plan as well as the guidance
for climate change adaption and draft
conservation area owner guidance
points of concern and suggestions for
future heritage
designation and projects have also been
outlined and these points will be used
to form the council's work going forward
the document will now form an important
reference document
to positively aid residents and
developers when they are looking to
carry out works in the ramsgate
conservation area
it provides evidence to support the plan
planning decisions of the council and a
framework for future heritage
initiatives therefore i recommend to
cabinet that we put the appraisal and
plan forward for formal adoption by the
council do i have a seconder
councillor david saunders
to speak under 20.1 councillor
crittenden
thank you um i am pleased to see the
ramsgate conservation area appraise will
come to cabinet for approval and as you
have said it is an excellent document
and i'm sure it will be a point of
reference for years to come
i've got just a couple of points i'd
like to raise and the first is a phrase
within the covering report where it
refers to heritage assets
i would like to request that it is
specified that this term includes war
memorials and monuments
the appraisal itself identifies several
monuments and war memorials by name and
location throughout the document so by
default it could be deemed that they are
already covered
however evidence suggests that a
specific reference to all memorials and
monuments would enable us to better keep
them in our focus
i would like to illustrate the need for
this through the situation regarding one
of those memorials that has several
mentions in the appraisal
destiny in albion gardens the first
world war statue that is one of the
venues for the annual remembrance day
services
following an extensive restoration in
november 2004 the report war memorials
in thanet was approved by cabinet in
october 2005
and included the recommendation that
destiny received a biennial application
of a shelter coat
i've been liaising with senior officers
with regard to the welfare of our
monuments and memorials and now know
that destiny will not have had a shelter
coat since at least
2015.
this has undoubtedly contributed to the
very poor condition she is now in and
she is once again in need of an
extensive restoration
the situation is now on the radar so to
speak but i hope you will agree that to
help ensure that our memorials and
monuments get a specific recognition
by by specifying that heritage assets
include war memorials and monuments
this is a matter of interest not just
the ramsgate conservation area of course
but to all the towns and villages within
our district where there are monuments
and more memorial and memorials
so i'm hoping that we can actually add
a specification that heritage assets do
include these
my second point is
i wanted to raise is not for
consideration tonight but just to note
from the top of page 148 of the
appraisal it describes the granville
theatre as a valuable community immunity
and i hope that this might be born in
mind should cabinet have any further
involvement in the decision making
regarding the future of this building
thank you
thank you councillor crenden um i will
need to refer to
mr livingston for response on the um the
item regarding the uh memorials
thank you leela um just to just come
back on the question about heritage
asset definition uh to be absolutely
clear that the historic england
definition of um of a heritage asset
includes monuments
there they are
they are
subject to planning control uh there are
recently uh changes that have been made
to legislation to ensure that monuments
need planning permission to be taken
down for example and so it is covered in
that definition fundamentally
we can look at the report before it
supports accounts just to see whether or
not it needs a specific reference but in
terms of national legislation it is
considered that they are heritage assets
thank you
um i'm not really sure who i can refer
to regarding the um the uh shelter coat
i wouldn't even begin to think about
what they actually look like um
all right so that's in hand so you're
happy with that one so that's been
followed up okay
um referring to the um
the the uh the granville um
it is important for this council to
ensure
that we find a long
and sustainable future for all of our
assets going forward and that
is considered very heavily in any
decision that we make so um
i can uh this this applies to all of our
our assets you know it is a priority
that we actually find
a real
um
future and that they are not left to to
in a derelict state so that will be
worn into account when we make any
decisions about any assets within the
council's portfolio
so i have moved and seconded uh does
everybody agree
it's agreed charles
i know
right okay
so i'm going to ask um for the live
stream to be terminated for for this
meeting if you can arrange that please
charles